do you think those like those drug
dealers that failed chemistry in high
school and they're making they're
cooking the crack up or whatever and
they're like man I think I really like
science
you know if I were to redo it all I
think I'd be really good at it
[Music]
Ryan you might be interested in this one
cool there's a Philadelphia towing
company that has been charged in a multi
multi-million dollar catalytic converter
theft range
so they tow cars and they just secretly
smart basically that's why you should
buy electric cars
they don't have
this charger now uh this past week is
against 11 people and a Philadelphia
towing company and a multi-million
dollar catalytic converter death ring
wow basically saying that the TDI Towing
in Philadelphia's Port Richmond Section
bought 8.2 million dollars worth of
catalytic converters over the last three
years wow that's the real crime if the
crime is being the person that buys them
really yeah I totally agree with what
you're saying yeah yeah but it is
sending out his guys to go steal him and
stuff but that's also bad but not as bad
as buying them buy them and then resells
all the so if he hires them to steal it
why does he have to buy it from the guys
that are stealing it because he's the
middleman because that's how they make
the money too because like that's their
incentive to go steal it but why don't
they just pay um to go steal it instead
of just buying it after you pay him to
go steal it I'm confused
check this out right oh okay
okay he steals it yeah and then he
charges me extra for stealing it why am
I charging you extra why that's what I'm
saying why don't I just pay you one time
India you already paid him he's your
employee yeah yeah so he just gives it
for free to you yeah that's what I'm
saying that is what they're doing no but
then that sounded like to me he was he
was I was paying him to go steal it and
then after he brought it he's selling it
to me I think it's in addition to that
so that he's got a people stealing it
but they also fence it yeah he's gonna
go get it you're gonna give him money
okay then he works for me flat rate and
then use yourself that's what he said
so you can sell it back to the owner of
the car you know it's just that's that's
that's what exactly
double the price so basically
um they're they're taking yes their
employees in in whatever way that you
see fit uh and they're just stealing a
bunch of [__] catalytic converters
they're giving it to this you know this
towing company and whatnot that's also
reselling you know stripping it for
parts and taking the actual you know
really really expensive because that's
the harder thing to find it's harder to
find somebody to fence your uh converter
that you stole really that's why they go
so far they'll be someone in Atlanta
that's buying the one stolen in La it's
like crazy whoa yeah that's how they get
away with it yeah prosecutors are saying
that this guy Michael Williams who runs
TDI Towing uh is the Kingpin he's got
six employees many of whom are related
to him oh they're also charged family
business investigators say these
suspects bought the converters which
were brought to TDI Towing all hours of
the night but they're also stealing them
see now I understand the difference
he has employees stealing and bringing
it but there's not enough enough so he's
taking it from free agents too that are
selling it to all yes oh wow he takes
all cameras he's a fence yeah
investigative around the business yeah
yeah investigators say the company
bought an average of 175 converters per
week per week of 300 each and we're
reselling the precious metals which are
rhodium Platinum the Palladium also he
wasn't reselling the converters no he
was just stripping it that's like a meth
head yeah that game will get you caught
reselling the converter you have to just
take the metal out really and he added
the the value of these Metals increased
dramatically during the pandemic because
of Supply chains Yeah so basically the
staff room was like really optimized
during the supply chain crisis uh of all
these someone was buying Black Market
rhodium wait a minute or maybe
this this guy this guy have a science
background or something why does he know
this stuff you know like how do you get
these metals from color converter you
know just it's crazy a lot of catalytic
converters get stolen because it's
there's a lot of expensive stuff and
it's easy to just take off yeah yeah but
it's also crazy that like criminals
they're like they failed chemistry but
they're also making drugs and cooking
them in Colombia I know isn't that crazy
like people that like you would think
did really poorly in school but they're
actually very good at running a lot
nation's good well there's also a
difference between like being really
good at math or being just really good
at the quadratic equation that's true
you know what I mean like versus like
which is the drug dealer
drug dealers really good at one thing
but it doesn't mean they're like a
chemist arithmetic yeah do you think
those like those drug dealers that
failed chemistry in high school they're
making they're cooking the crack up or
whatever and they're like man I think I
really like science
you know if I were to redo it all I
think I'd be really good at it I can't
check the salaries of scientists okay
I'm gonna still do the strong thing
it's always crazy though when
something's like a a whole racket you
know like a theft Ring versus like you
know because we we oftentimes think or
at least I oftentimes think of like a
crime in maybe one dimension just
committing Like A to B as a crime versus
like thinking about the entire industry
of it and like figuring out how to like
think about the system beat the system
with these loopholes get different
people in different parts in order to
cover certain tracks you know what I'm
saying like you got to be still skilled
to know how to like run that entire ring
or be considered a Kingpin of something
you know that's why they're trying to
catch all the of those guys it's just
like with pawn shops when the pawn shops
can't accept stolen cameras
so now you that's like how they helped
with theft is like you just can't get
rid of it you can't offload it but then
now it's like people are traveling so
far to like like there was like these
huge rings that happened in like the
middle of Texas where like from all the
surrounding states they were just truck
in all the catalytic converters and this
one place would just take them because
they also know the one guy that will
accept the precious metals because
that's also not everybody because some
people are like they don't want to take
the risk right yeah wow so now there's
gonna be a homeless guy just on his
bicycle with a catalytic converter over
his shoulder just going all over town
like no one wants to buy this yeah I'm
gonna stick to collecting cans he got no
buyers bro that's why the only thing the
only thing you can do is either take out
your cat converter or lower your car
by the way we would discuss the story
maybe we should play the background
music from uh It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia
we'll never read a Philadelphia Story I
always have the music
anytime they're doing something
degenerate
stealing catalytic converters yeah we
can play music for like maybe five
seconds at a time before we get
copyright issues though oh oh yeah oh
it's five seconds now it used to be
seven seconds right unless it's a Teresa
Tang Song
so they're okay with it people like this
doesn't have to be monetized we're
talking Teresa tank you know what Teresa
no I don't know doesn't need you what
she's like an old school singer no oh
[__] I thought you would know
oh oh I didn't know her English name oh
what's the what's the Chinese name of
course I know her but then I pronounce
it right oh no there is a tank that's
her English name but I I never knew her
English name you know wow until now yeah
we played her music for our Mexican
friend oh and he got like pretty horny I
think oh really he said she was he said
she was very pretty wait a minute was he
listening to her music or is her picture
and reading the English translations see
there's no way I can tell anymore
they're too many senses that's being
stimulated there
which one it is he was so turned on I
think yeah oh okay it's crazy though
that when when certain Metals rise in
price those things just get stolen more
like copper
yeah when copper went up all the wiring
was being stripped for every building
whoa yeah like new construction
oh all these methods were jumping in and
just and then when wood went up they
started stealing whole giant like train
loads of wood from The Yards yeah oh you
know who I saw [__] stealing [__] the
other day but this truck so like I live
in Vegas
yeah I live in Vegas I could come out
here to shoot but in Vegas you know it's
like a rapidly developing Place yeah so
they're always building new [__] there's
this park that's being built and so
while they're building they just kind of
fence off like a bunch of plants I saw a
truck roll up and the people just
started carrying it stealing the plants
wow and just throw in the back of the
pickup truck plants are expensive yeah
plants are expensive man yeah especially
they're like hundreds of dollars per per
treat yeah no palm trees yeah
grown palm trees palm trees baby that
could be like 20 grand for the grown
ones yeah 20. look at it like man I
can't buy some more crypto with that
imagine the palm tree theft ring be
tough you better steal it before it's
planted yeah no you guys still after
they're planted what
just to make him go what
I'm like unless you're on an excavator I
got little palm trees growing all the
time if you want it oh you got little
palm trees growing all the time what
does that even mean because I have a big
palm tree that dispenses seeds and then
there's little ones that Sprout we don't
want to do that much work man we just
want to steal them I just put it in a
pot for you and you can grow it
apologies for you dude that's so much
water for like years it's 20 G's after
it's like this big yeah you know what
was getting stolen live in a rainy Place
one of the hottest items I was getting
stolen in Hollywood was uh the
headlights and I think the grill of the
G wagon the Top Model oh
yeah because that's all you needed to
put on your lower class G model to make
it look like the best model so people
were just taking those parts isn't that
odd it's kind of smart very smart plus
you're luck looking at the Richer person
than you like you don't [__] need
this yeah yeah yeah that's how you just
that's already a nice car stealing
something to put on another nice I know
which is like ironic right it's like you
can afford a nice car still but no
I miss stealing sometimes wait wait wait
wait
let's do this off record
look people don't want to say it but
stealing is a lot of fun
[Music]